[Music]
stick stands necklace sword going off
his numbers from last year you could
make the cases become one of the best
shooters in the realm you can never have
too much shooting Steph
Klay your thoughts oh yeah oh yeah offer
I think it's on safe a bit shaky I think
swaggy P could be an asset yes Patrick
Raven just came in which Sean's bomb
household it has traded for Dwight
Howard good for them nothing to concern
ourselves with Thank You Patrick let us
know if you hear of anything else
hi Lord Commander swaggy has his moments
but all too often plays the fool they
said the same of Javel but I'd say he's
worked out quite nicely I just I worry
how many of these Jester types can we
absorb until yes Patrick another raven
he's across the Narrow Sea
who firkin for cat fur ken korkmaz Oh
Patrick
they say you might make the sixes active
roster hope okay Patrick maybe just
notify us if any big names change houses
understood right right
big names got it awful one think Nick's
presence will help he's one of the best
catch and shoot guys out there I an Lal
Walton speaks well of his defense I mean
I like the Lord it's just another raven
sure it is run but it's a big name
hall-of-famer okay Vince Carter he's
joining house Kings were not worried
about house kings Patrick Byrne punch
but you said big names and a four years
old Patrick I don't know I just get a
bad feeling about him yeah how about
this only inform us of anything that
actually matters to a house of our
stature so say one of the Great Houses
of the West makes a move that directly
affects us that sort of thing right
something that hurts our chances right
got it if you think it's a good fit
that'll know his role you may be right
this is not the swaggy P of your he's
known his uncle swaggy now all right
so disagreed he'll be examined by the
maces on the morrow and if they deem him
fit that a contract should major news
multiple references better be good yes
sir Chris Paul has been traded to house
rockets but wait there's more Jimmy
Butler is joining karl-anthony and the
maple night in Minnesota yeah and
there's more it's worth Paul George and
Carmelo Anthony will be joining the
Brody on house Thunder that's three new
super houses all in the West again
Patrick please only bring us news that
actually affects our chances
[Music]
we've got stuff your chair are you okay
yeah just that tweaked my ankle no big
deal play
clay get down from there get off the
scaffolding you be mad I'm just trying
to see my portable clay I'm good I'm
good
it's just me thumb Oh God let me help
you play Kevin just tweaked my ribs a
bit not to worry
ah Oh Trey Maude what's wrong with you
now I don't know
just send in a raven of mere pelvic area
and the Raven just bit me in by any
relativity up a pelvic area
you